على سرير الشفاء يرقض عمرو الحاج من حلحول
شمالي الخليل وقد تغيرت ملامح وجهه بعد
تعرضه للضرب والسحل من قبل جنود الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي توثق هذه اللقطات التي انتشرت
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ما واجهه عمر
خلال اقتحام قوات الاحتلال ل البلده قبل
ايام اج الجيش من ورانا ما كنا في جيش ولا
كان في مواجهات اصلا ورانا اعتدوا علينا
الضرب بالاسلحه
بذيت تفوا علينا وغلطوا علينا برضو فظل
يضرب فينا لحتى يعني ز زهقوا بالعربي
زهقوا من الكت اللي ضربونا اياه بعدها
بقول له خلاص مش قادر عيني مش قادر اللي
هو بجيب فلفل ورشه في عينيه مشهد اخر من
مشاهد الاعتداءات على الفلسطينيين في
الضفه الغربيه والتي زادت منذ السابع من
اكتوبر
[موسيقى]
الماضي
مستوطن يطلق النار على الشاب زكريا العدرا
من قريه لتواني في مسافر يطا جنوبي الخليل
بعد عمليه طوفان الاقصى بايام امضى زكريا
83 يوما وهو يتلقى العلاج في المستشفى
طلعنا سمعنا صوت البلاد ناس بقول مستوطنين
مستوطنين يعني انا طلعت المسجد بس 20 متر
مسافه 20 متر فال المستوطن يعني كان
لاقيني المستوطن هو حامل عه وضربني فيه
هنا ورجع على طول مسافه متر زي هيك وع طول
طخت رصاص دمدم اه فضربت في بطني من الشقه
هذه فكسر لي ثلاث طلوع من صدري وكان
الشفرات مشيات في بطنه ثلاثه ومنذ بدء
معركه طوفان الاقصى اتخذ وزراء في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه عددا من الاجراءات شجعت
المستوطنين على زياده اعتداءاتهم ضد
الفلسطينيين
وممتلكاتهم ابرزها خطه توزيع السلاح وخطه
المناطق العازله في محيط المستوطنات على
ما يبدو ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه
كشفت عن انيابها بشكل كبير عن المخططات
القديمه التي كانت ق اتفقت عليها ما بين
تحالف بنم نتنياهو وتمار بن كفير وبسم وس
متريش والتي يعني نتج عنها ما يقارب 225
اعتداء على 93 مدينه وقريه في الضف
الغربيه بالاضافه الى وجود تمويل حكومي
جريد فاق 75 مليون شيكل لاقاه بور جريد و
تزايد عددها بعد 7 اكتوبر الى 14 بوره
استيطاني و22 طريق استيطاني جديد حواجز
ونقاط عسكريه جديده اقيمت عند مداخل المدن
والبلدات في الضفه الغربيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر تقطع هذه الحواجز الاوصال بين
المدن والقرى ويعتبرها الكثير من
الفلسطينيين وسيله يستخدمها جنود الاحتلال
لايقافه واعتقالهم والاعتداء عليهم تشير
كل المعطيات على الارض الى ان الاعتداءات
الاسرائيليه ضد الفلسطينيين في الضف
الغربيه زادت بشكل ملحوظ منذ عمليه طوافان
الاقصى في السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
اعتداءات وتضييق زاد من حجمها هذه
البوابات والحواجز التي قد تنتهي عندها
حياه الفلسطيني لمجرد الاشتباه به منتصر
نصارى الجزيره الخليل جنوب الضفه الغربيه